president biden is being urged to treat
fentanyl overdose deaths with the same
intensity as covid the street version of
the deadly drug that's made in china and
smuggled in through the southern border
is devastating our country fueling in
large part a record hundred thousand
americans dying from ods last year
an organization called families against
fentanyl is asking the biden
administration to count fentanyl
poisoning and overdose deaths the same
way accounts covid19 deaths they claim
that data could help medical officials
pinpoint hot spots
and surge resources to save lives this
sounds like a good idea right greg i
guess so i mean there's a lot of you
could definitely solve a lot of these
problems by just with common sense the
problem always is going to be demand
and if you criminalize the substance the
demand moves towards the criminal so in
a perfect world this drug would not
exist we wouldn't need it and you
couldn't get it anywhere but the fact is
people make opiates and the criminal
supply will always be there which is why
you should be easing restrictions on the
pharmacy it's just like during
prohibition if you take uh if you ban
boost then it's the still and the still
has its hazards so people are picking up
on drugs whether it's xanax or pot or
opiates it's counterfeit and it's filled
with fentanyl that's why we don't call
them overdoses we call them poisonings
so right now the best thing to do right
now would be to ease up on restrictions
don't drive people out of the street and
perhaps start legalizing it i would love
to see it otc at some point but i'm not
holding my breath the other thing too is
you got to treat it like mass murder a
hundred thousand from china it's
interesting to me because you know if he
wants to treat it like covet it's like
well
it came from china too but if we bring
that up is that racist but it is coming
from china that's true and we and trump
had the idea of bombing i think it was
like bombing drug dealers in mexico and
everybody freaked out why it's they're
terrorists right yeah narco terrorists
yeah dana i mean it's it's good
policy just because you want to save
lives but it's great politics to to
focus on it like this but also because
of these deaths it really is another a
major bipartisan issue this is this does
not discriminate for the families that
are republicans or democrats this is
actually hurting everyone in that nbc
poll that we've referenced a couple of
times immigration was still in the top
five of issues that means that it is
really much on people's minds and part
of that is the drugs that are coming
into the country now the administration
has a week to decide on about title 42
we've already seen bill mollusion's
reporting today incredible just the
waves of people coming across and that
we know from the government's own
documentation that they expect eighteen
thousand
more crossings a day which means how
many got aways would there be and how
many drugs would be coming across uh if
you wanted to galvanize the country
against something
like china
and fentanyl and for americans you could
do that very easily with this you sure
could and because it's so small geraldo
anybody can bring it over it's very hard
to detect
i think that while i generally agree
with greg on the treatment of
illicit drugs i think that there is such
a thing as a prohibition mentality and
as you restrict it so the the demand uh
grows
but you also greg said something that
was uh was different that was uh
important that the distinction between
fentanyl and drugs there's a drug
overdose and then there is a poisoning
if there's a poisoning that is a crime
that is a manslaughter i believe that
what you have to do here is to treat
this
the the so every one of those 107 000
overdoses got the poison from somebody
right yep i'm not talking about mexican
i'm talking about the somebody who
poisoned three people on the block
at the retail level let's have some
high-profile prosecutions let's have a
federal task force we're really young
aggressive da's to go out there and
don't go for the cartel which is
unattainable right now for at least by
at the local level go for the guy on the
corner go for him and whack him with a
manslaughter indictment and you know
that
the the the circle around the junkie
knows who gave him the dope gave him the
poison in this case they know that it
was freddy or mikey or sammy uh and he's
notorious for it and he's spiking the
cocaine and
whack him with a manslaughter indictment
let's see how many of those
can alter
some conduct if it's promoted in a
bipartisan way we're going after them
it's not the war on drugs it's the war
on the killers it's the it's the
manslaughterers would you buy into that
route judge
well
you know i i believe that certainly
manslaughter is appropriate and in terms
of my career i'm sure i've prosecuted
for manslaughter someone who gave
someone drugs that they knew was uh what
was dangerous or they knew the person
would overdose that's nothing new
however this is the difference saying i
was unoriginal
here's the difference
when you say you prosecute them for
manslaughter that's great but that's not
how i did drug crimes i you know i
wouldn't end up with just the local guy
i'd squeezed him until he was nothing
left to squeeze you can keep going up
that ladder and going up that ladder
until you get the big guy and i think
the sooner we recognize that this is an
undeclared war by china against the
united states and the number one uh age
group of people who are dying of this
fentanyl poisoning not overdose
poisoning are men between the ages of 18
and 45. now if you if you have a war
think about even ukraine what are the
ages of men who end up going to war 18
to 45. i mean there is an undeclared war
that they've declared against us and so
i think the better the the the better
and your your your idea is is i'm sure
is good but we've got to start
recognizing that if we don't take them
down if entitled 42
damn title 42 but what we've got to do
is recognize that it will be the end of
of of crime the way we see it today it
will flourish over the next decade if
they end title 42 because the cartels
are licking their chops they're getting
money they're money laundering and
they're invading the united states
i think you've got to make a distinction
between fentanyl and drugs i think
okay and we have here
we have all right don't go anywhere
kamala harris
cooking up another serving of word salad
this latest embarrassment ahead
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now